hey believe nation its Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you and I
want to see that thing you've got inside
of you come out and have a big impact on
the world I started that meant to me
serious - hang on people who've done
more than us and hopefully we can learn
from them the way they think their
mindsets their beliefs to help us be the
best version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from Robin Sharma and
some of his productivity tips mentor me
Robin rule number two is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around us how other people
can be inspired as well and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself to enjoy
[Music]
the way you begin each day sets up the
way you live each day I mean the Spartan
warriors set it so well
sweat morn training bleed lesson war and
if you want to be literally undefeatable
in business literally unstoppable in
life you really want to dial in your
morning routine and so you want to do
things like starting the day sweating
because that releases BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor that repairs brain
cells from stress you want to sweat
because that's going to increase your
metabolic rate which is going to give
you energy and we live in a world where
energy is even more valuable than it
intelligence you want to in your morning
routine take the time to write in a
journal so you actually can detect your
values reconnect with your goals each
day get to know yourself even more
because awareness is the beginning of
transformation and you want to get your
morning routine right so you take some
time at the front end of your day to
learn because as you learn more you know
you're gonna achieve more and as you
understand better you can achieve larger
your environment is so important and if
you look at be performers or see
producers they really don't pay a lot of
tension to their environment and so they
get very distracted there's lots of
noises their phones are going off maybe
there's news in the background maybe
there's messy environments all around
them
maybe there's toxic people what I'm
suggesting to you is the second piece of
technology to really 100 times your
productivity is this install
environments of tight bubbles of total
focus the way I run my work life on
certain days
I am very hard to reach and I challenge
you with great love and respect be very
hard to reach during key times of your
week I mean I see a lot of people and
it's not judging them it's just
observing them every time their phone
rings they check it or they have you
know these loud notifications so they're
constantly being distract
did and we know what the research says
the research says we spend 2.1 hours a
day in distraction we spent and it takes
21 minutes to refocus your focus after
you've been distracted so if you are
being distracted by notifications
checking your phone checking your
Twitter feed checking your Facebook feed
looking on Instagram checking all the
different platforms that is going to
destroy your focus so the second piece
of Technology's create these tight
bubbles of total focus and the way I do
it is I have certain days that I label
as creative days and on those creative
days I actually go device free and on
those days I'm very hard to find and on
those days I'm in total solitude and on
those days I go to certain places I
called them my Menlo labs just like
Edison had his Menlo lab and these
places are very minimalist and there's
no one there and that's where I do my
best work so install these tight bubbles
of total focus and create these Menlo
labs where you're sorry you're
completely distraction free and then you
will find your brain will drop from the
beta state into the alpha state where
you will do your best work and get your
best ideas all ideas don't work unless
you do the work and some of the best
work you can do is getting really good
at creating a one-page plan have your
big 5 the 5 things that need to happen
this year for this to be your best year
yet
on a one-page plan your top 5 values put
them on that same plan your top 5 sub
goals sequenced into each quarter of
this year on that one page plan and
every morning while your competition or
the rest of the world is asleep get up
at 5 a.m. I'll teach you how to do that
in future videos but look at your
one-page plan to spend 20 minutes on
that so it becomes a brain tattoo a
burning obsession so it all lights you
with inspiration so you blow up the
world and you understand the clarity is
power and you so intimately know what
has to happen during this day this week
this month this quarter this year to get
you closer to your mountaintop
because the ordinary though the hours
that ordinary people waste extraordinary
people do because they're not bored like
most people most people need to medicate
themselves with too much TV
too much Facebook too much video too
much chitchat too much busyness because
they don't know their goals because they
don't have a one page plan because they
don't have a one page schedule I mean
I've got my schedule for every 7 days
almost everything I need to do goes on
it and you might say Robin well that's a
very rigid way to live no it's a very
free way to live because then I have the
power to live life on my own terms I
feel inspired I'm not wasting each day
I'm leveraging each day the myth of the
harder I work the more productive I will
be is has been debunked by the science
if you study human performance just what
they've realized that Jim Lehrer and
Tony Schwartz have done some great work
in this field but here's what the
science says optimal performance and
productivity happens in 90-minute cycles
so what am I saying work for 90 minutes
and then take a break to recover then
work for not another 90 minutes and then
go for a walk and then work for another
90 minutes and then take a drink of
water and then work for another 90
minutes and maybe take a nap or read
something interesting that's not related
to what you were doing what will that do
it will keep your mind focused on the
work at hand it will increase your
energy because energies like it well you
deplete it you need to fill out the well
again and it will really keep you and
your productive best and also keep you
inspired rather than getting burned out
I think a product pick up position pick
something to focus on and then have the
business discipline to really focus on
that one thing
and do it brilliantly even personally it
more and more I think you know
ultimately build your personal life
around five things and that's it build
your business or your team around five
key opportunities and say no no
everything else and that's the secret of
mastery if you look at the the true
masters they basically record out one
thing that
trying to be graded everything I just
finished my Monday morning meeting with
my team in it we went over when I call
my eight priorities and this is for for
this year the whole organization all our
energy
all our raisers all our focus is really
around the 8 things that are on this
page right now and any other
opportunities that come in we pretty
much say no to it any other speaking
opportunities that come in if they're
not aligned with you know the tour is
that we have on the schedule for this
year we say no to it and that brings up
another key point which is most
businesses run into trouble not because
of too many good opportunities but
because they excuse me not because they
didn't have enough good opportunities
but because of too many good
opportunities so they were going here
and there and everywhere and they got
really busy being busy so they couldn't
focus on those five key things or on
that one big opportunity focus focus
focus a key thing to building a great
black brand building a great business
and building a world-class life the next
piece of technology that will help you
create exponential productivity in your
work life so you truly impact the world
around you is choose your peer group
really really well there's a lot of
excellent science coming out and a lot
of excellent research coming out that
says the number one way to improve your
behavior is to surround yourself with a
peer group or social circle of people
who are also playing at the level you
want to be playing at so if you want to
be a high performer in terms of your
product productivity populate your life
with high performers now here's the
science behind it in the brain we have
something called the mirror neuron
system of the brain and it dates back to
thousands of years ago when we were
living on the Savannah and this mirror
neuron system allowed us to model the
behavior of the dominant people in the
tribe so if someone figured out a tool
or figured out fire or a better way to
survive
subconsciously this system in the brain
allowed us to model the behavior and I
think this is pretty fascinating
information now here we are in the
modern world and what happens
subconsciously we are modeling the
behave
year of the people we spend most of our
time with and so if you are around
victims you will start behaving like a
victim if you are still around people
who are mediocre performers you will
subconsciously start behaving like them
if you around people who gossip who are
not a players who do not produce very
much you will subconsciously because if
the mirror neuron system in the brain
start performing like them why else is
it important to surround yourself with a
pure set or social orbit of a player's
emotional contagion and that's a
scientific phenomenon that simply says
we pick up on the emotions of the people
that are around us and so if you are
around a social circle of people who are
inspired people who want to do great
work people who want to be ultra
productive people who want to be
innovative people who are relentlessly
optimizing their work their thinking
their creativity just being around them
will allow you to adopt their energy and
their ways of being a stress is not your
enemy there's another myth which is Oh
stress diminishes my energy stress gets
makes me unproductive stress makes me
tired stress is actually a very valuable
tool it's a force that pushes you past
your comfort zone and extends and grows
your capability intellectually when
you're pushed against the tough problem
or a deadline it increases your your
mental capability physically when you
are pushed beyond your physical comfort
zone whether it's through running more
or lifting more weights or doing more
physically that will actually grow your
capability but here's the key stress is
not the enemy a lack of refueling and
renewing and recovery against the stress
you face every day at work is really
what depletes your resources and causes
you to lose your productivity to lose
your momentum to lose
innovation to lose your energy here's
what I'm suggesting everyday find some
time to recover and renew again stress
some ideas your work at one of the best
things you do one hour a day to work out
push yourself reader yourself through
energy another simple idea meditation
meditation is gone mainstream it's
nothing new agey it's nothing soft
there's a ton of scientific data that
will show you to renew your energy and
your mental focus so you are at your
product the best meditation is a great
way to do do that number another simple
tip to recover is just shift gears so if
you were working on a piece of creative
work pick up something maybe some light
reading for 10 or 15 minutes something
that makes you feel a bit relaxed it
will give you that recovery and then the
final tip that is really really
important go for a walk and you just go
walk around the block so you reset your
mindset so you come back even more
energized thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you take from this video
what was a single most important message
that you are going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down in the comments below I
look forward to hearing what you have to
say I also want to give a quick shout to
bull Hawkins from four-minute masters
both thank you so much for picking up a
cup of my book your one word I'm doing
the review on your YouTube channel I
really really really appreciate it and
I'm so glad you enjoyed the book hey
guys today we're gonna be talking about
every karma comes your one word the
powerful secrets creating up is this
life that matters thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon